foreign
[Music]
my name is Greg swinehart I have worked
at our studio for a long time
um this is going to be a different kind
of talk for our studio conf because I'm
not a data scientist I'm a graphic
designer like I graduated in the social
sciences so why on Earth am I up here to
talk to you I'm asking myself the exact
same question
um let's see can we get my slides up
here on the screen
here we go
so I started uh I think the first design
I did for our studio I think three
people worked there at the time
um and uh joined full-time about four
and a half years ago I made this back in
the day actually and this started out as
a shirt a couple years before hexes were
even a thing
um Joe reached out and said I kind of
want to make a baseball shirt with this
thing I've been working on can you make
us a shirt that says shiny and kind of
baseball fun and then when hexes came
around we controversially went with the
baseball fonts where all the other hexes
had a different fonts it was very uh it
was there were some tense conversations
but we got it now it's no big deal of
course
[Music]
um
so a few months ago I moved over to the
shiny team to see what you all have been
working on and see if maybe we could
update some things in the process what
we're going to talk about today is kind
of what I've seen in the last couple
months and what we've begun to work on
to uh to build some new functionality
for you to make your lives a little bit
easier so I'm going to talk about three
simple design principles that might help
your shiny apps look and feel a little
bit better as you're building them and
and also show some of the new work that
were that we've just begun
to help your apps look and feel a little
bit better automatically
all right so what's it like to be a
graphic designer
I hate it I seriously hate it I hate it
you guys know what I'm talking about
like you're looking at a thing and it's
just not working it is horrible
sometimes I mean don't get me wrong 99
of the time it's like the greatest thing
I could possibly be doing with my time
it's the joy of my life to do it
um but then when you get to that thing
you guys know what I'm talking about
like you have that thing it just doesn't
look or feel right and you start to kind
of meddle with some things to try and
fix it and there's a million different
directions you could go and none of them
are working and then it's just like ah I
hate it
so I just bring that up to say that
I understand what you're going through
sometimes when you're making your apps
and you're trying to make them look good
we totally get it and uh and we're
working on it we're trying to make this
world a little bit easier for you here's
here's how I think of design
is a form of communication
communicating well
it's really difficult
constructing the perfect message is a
lot of work and then if you add the
complexity of saying it away that your
audience will hear or even pay attention
to
it could really feel like nearly
impossible
so uh
so putting an app in front of somebody
in my mind all the work that you guys
are doing it's like having a
conversation with them and that's why
I'm here to talk about how designing for
people is hard
Maybe
you tell me maybe 10 of the work that
you're doing when you're working on a
shiny app is front end work
and yet you're supposed to have this
Rock Solid data and also an amazing UI
and ux experience for your users
that's a really big ask
so our goal here is for you to be able
to make better and More Beautiful apps
and maybe have that even take up less of
your time that's kind of what we're
trying to work towards
so when I got to the shiny team
they asked me one question how can we
make shiny apps look better side
question please tell us it doesn't
involve HTML and CSS
historically the benefit of shining has
been you can make something decent
without knowing HTML and CSS but
admittedly as Joe said yesterday there
have been gaps in improving this default
look
Joe recognize a long list of people in
the community who have stood in this Gap
like David granjin and his work on bs4
Dash without the work of David and how
many other people were on that list it
was like a million six
um the apps would still look like they
were 10 years old probably
it's right now without adding on some
things a fresh shiny app can look
a little stale so where do we start
well
there's two things I want to talk about
today look
and functionality
look is kind of its default theme and
functionality is the components that
we're serving up to you so that you can
kind of present your data
let's start with look which means
we need to have some real talk
China uses bootstrap bootstrap 3 to
render its UI and bootstrap 3 was
created in 1852 I don't know the exact
date
so shiny looks stale because bootstrap 3
this year looks kind of stale and this
is not to speak ill of bootstrap 3 when
it came out it was a miracle
but if you're going to make a new shiny
app the best first step you can take
right now is to start with the latest
bootstrap and right now that is
bootstrap 5.
bootstrap 5 uh is will make it look much
more contemporary right out of the box
it has more components for us to serve
to you has better accessibility tools
which is amazing and of course it makes
your app look responsive and appropriate
for whatever size screen it's on
so how do you do this you can easily do
this it's almost like I was looking at
how they do this it's literally like
somebody said Hey Siri make this
bootstrap 5. that's kind of like what
they do and they do it with this r
package called BS lib by
someone who could only be described as
the greatest human being on the planet
Carson sievert he has really done yeah
this guy has done the Lord's work for
like two and a half years to make this
process easy for you
you might remember that Joe Chang
mentioned BS lib at the 2020 conference
he actually gave a whole talk about it
so BS lib provides tools to easily
customize bootstrap and therefore your
app's appearance directly from R
allowing you to quickly change the
appearance of your shiny apps and for
that matter our markdown in quarto stuff
today we're going to talk just about
shiny but it can't be overstated how
easy it is to change your shiny app's
appearance to match your organized
organization's branding with just a few
lines of code this is where I come from
we need this thing but it has to have
our branding
just some happy BS live in there
This is Where I Come From you know we
need this and we need it to look like
Johnson and Johnson it's kind of like
all right well I'm going to look at the
red we got to make it red we got to look
at the typeface there's a couple key uh
SAS variables that you can Target to
really kind of change the look of your
entire thing BS lib
can make it very simple with one or two
lines of code or it gives you access to
all what is it 1400 different SAS
variables to change your your bootstrap
theme
and so you can go as deep as you want
and this should be in kind of a scalable
reproducible way right so bslib is
unbelievable okay
so that's look you're off to a great
start
if you update your bootstrap to
bootstrap 5 with BS lib maybe you're
putting in a couple colors to match your
organization's branding
let's move on to functionality and get
some to some design principles that
occurred to me while I was looking
through kind of any shiny app I could
get my hands on in the last couple
months
I've been pouring through all of them
from the simplest ones to
some of them are behemoths they're crazy
they're nuts but everything in there is
important you can't judge it and here
are a few a few different design
principles came to mind while I looked
at them and when I was discussing with
those with the team we started coming up
with new functionality in reaction to
those design principles so let's get
started the first one comes from
the Gestalt uh principles of design now
whether designers know it or not they're
building things with these principles in
mind or as the foundation if you're
following them people will be able to
easily look at your app if you're
breaking them you kind of don't want to
look at the app anymore
um every designer is using this whether
they know it or not
so the first one
well actually I wanted to say that
Gestalt psychology uh is about 100 years
old
um and it is all about how we process
visual information
um when you look at something it turns
out you kind of look at the whole of
something you don't look at the parts of
it like when you look at a bike you
don't go
well look at that little uh pedal right
there well there's two petals here oh my
gosh then look there's Wheels right next
to it what's going on here and like
handle like you don't do that you look
at it you go that's a bike and if you
want to know you know specific things
about the bike you can then zero in same
thing with web design you want that kind
of whole thing to immediately be
something that they want to dive into
so the first principle that I want to
talk about here is proximity users will
mentally group together objects that are
spatially close to each other
now they're going to do this no matter
what so if you have information on one
side of your screen that's discussing
something that's on the other side of
your screen they're probably going to
group that information with something
else over here and then realize well
that's not quite right and they're going
to start fishing around for what they
should group that with it's really
better if you just keep things in
proximity
you know like the the most one of the
most popular ux books over the last 22
years is called don't make me think
you know we're really trying to serve
this up in a way so that they don't have
to like process too much they can just
engage with what you're trying to show
them in your app
so
what I want to do is kind of show you
some things that I saw I saw this quite
a bit and just kind of give you an
example of what proximity means right
here we've got a paragraph on the left
side in the sidebar
and it's speaking about something in
this kind of right part of the screen in
a perfect world those would be closer in
proximity and that that thing wouldn't
be in the sidebar that that language
would be over near the thing that it's
referencing
I also saw this and this isn't horrible
but
this is a title that kind of says this
that and the other thing and it's
talking about the three things
underneath that are about this that and
the other thing not horrible it's kind
of nice serving up what's coming Below
in a platter but it would be really nice
if the this and that and the other thing
were more closely in proximity with the
thing they were actually recording
and I'm also seeing this quite a bit
there are controls that are kind of
somewhere on your screen that control
somewhere else on your screen inputs and
outputs right and so um I've seen them
where it's kind of like you have to
start messing with them to see what they
control it'd be better if those controls
were closer to what they actually
controlled so let's clean this up real
quick we'll move this paragraph over
here this that and the other thing and
this really just says like we update
this one Wednesday mornings Let's uh
clean that up a little bit let's put the
controls actually where they need to be
to control something
starting to look a little bit cleaner
right we're causing the user to think
less before they engage with this thing
but do you notice how none of these
cards on the screen are the same height
or in some cases not even the same width
don't you wish they were kind of sized
like this
where the Gap in between the gutter in
between was the same
there's actually a design principle
behind this maybe you didn't notice it
but now that I've pointed it out did it
kind of make your skin crawl
uh this is called order things that are
aligned and symmetrical or more easily
processed when us when a person opens up
your app
you know what let's make them not think
as much as we can and let them really
kind of dive into the the meat and
potatoes of what you're trying to do
what you're trying to tell them all
right so let's clean this up we've got a
bunch of things here
all right this is starting to look a
little bit better
with proximity in order your users spend
less time trying to figure out how your
thing works and more time using it the
way you intend them to
um
but really I've just kind of been moving
stuff around right These are nice things
to keep in mind while you're building
your app but your mind is really in
other places while you're kind of
writing your R code and putting together
your data right
so we were trying to figure out is there
something here that we can put in the
process so that it can kind of put up
some guard rails so while you're
building these apps you'll kind of stay
in the lane and you don't have to think
about proximity because you're kind of
just put you know building everything in
proximity automatically
we realized this was the first piece of
functionality we should address
it's a card
um a lot of cards oftentimes become a
dashboard and from what I can tell
everybody in this room is like the Oprah
of dashboards you're just like you get a
dashboard you get a dashboard look under
your seat we all have a dashboard
um so a lot of dashboards everywhere and
I get it right you know how to make them
your users know how to consume them
everybody wins
um
bootstrap 3 didn't have cards guess what
bootstrap
so
we decided cards should become a
first-class citizen of shiny with NBS
lib and that they should look good
automatically so
we decided this
and then like we didn't hear from Joe
Chang for a day or two
and he came back with of course a fully
fledged card API for us to put into BS
lib this is what they look like by
default
pretty simple stuff
you get a card header for a title
this that or the other thing
you have a main idea maina area for
whatever you want it can be an image it
can be a plot it could be some pros a
button kind of whatever you can think of
you can throw it in there and if there's
any like tertiary information like we
updated this the other day
throw that in the bottom this does a lot
of the design the proximity and the in
in the order
heavy lifting for you
check this out here's a row of cards by
example here's what it would look like
no matter what you put in them they will
be
the same height because you know what
we're all grown-ups in this room and
maybe we can have nice things
uh sometime something bootstrap doesn't
offer but we think is really important
is sometimes you want to be able to
tweak the parameters of what is inside
the card
or maybe even just kind of change
wholesale what's showing in this card
and so you guys are very used to using
tabs and menus and drop downs and so
when you put that same code within this
card context it'll look like this and
give you the functionality of changing
what's inside the card
if you want to make dashboards right now
you're probably using Flex dashboard and
why wouldn't you so simple so clean for
a lot of you that's all you need you
want a little bit more uh functionality
you're probably using shiny dashboard or
maybe you're using bs4 Dash
we're building out in BS lib on top of
bootstrap 5.
a new UI toolkit for bslib
and once we're done you'll be able to
use its elements a la carte you'll be
able to kind of grab what you need
and not grab the rest basically you want
to have to import admin LTE to just put
a box around something
the things you love about those other
packages will be available in bslib and
therefore you'll be able to use them in
shiny our markdown Cordo
this is more of um Joe called it a
library approach more of a library
approach grab what you need just right
there and hopefully the design will look
good if you need to change some of the
branding go for it that's pretty easy
too
not everything needs to be a dashboard
but bringing in a little dashboard
elements now and then to your app can be
a pretty powerful thing
pretty good thing for your users so
let's talk about
um your users the last thing I want to
talk about is just information
architecture not from Gestalt but it's
when you look at your app let's say
you've narrowed down all of the content
to as as little as it can be
and it's still kind of a mess still
getting it's still kind of hard to
engage with this is where you can start
kind of prioritizing what you show based
on the users that you're going to be
presenting it to any app you make any
website you make any poster you make you
could probably prioritize who is going
to engage it you can come up with like
three or four different three or five
different users a lot of people call
them personas
so let's prioritize based on who's going
to be using it
and just show them what they need to
know the way that's easiest to
prioritize for your different users
is by how much time of your theirs you
have some people are going to be looking
at your dashboards maybe like a boss is
looking at a dashboard they have 30
seconds to get you know the main
headlines and then they're moving on to
check out like 15 other dashboards of 15
other departments
maybe there's a department leader that
has a couple minutes a couple times a
week
they probably need to know everything
that the boss needs to know they
probably also want to know a little bit
more so that stuff that they need to
know if it's too messy initially okay to
put that away behind the click
there's probably a third person who's a
specialist might spend all week every
week in your app and need to respond in
real time to what's happening there they
might need to really kind of drill down
and see some very specific things that
are happening
and so that is okay for them to click
behind the thing so what I want to do is
I want to show you what bslib looks like
in a live example here the stuff that
we've been making so we've got this
sidebar here
and we have decided that we had too much
in our sidebar so we've categorized them
into five different accordion menus
we're bringing in accordions you can
have them open or closed because we
think the boss would want to engage with
these first two we opened up those and
we close the rest accordions are going
to be a thing that you can kind of put
in wherever you want doesn't have to be
in the sidebar
all right so now we're going to engage
with this a little bit let's see
we're gonna bring in button groups from
bootstrap 5. that can also act as check
boxes or radios so in this app there's
three different airports let's see where
do we want to fly to I obviously want to
fly to Hawaii and I don't know where Bob
Hope is that Palm Springs I like Bob
Hope so we'll do that
all right so just for fun
close these because
that's fun here's another thing we can
do we're uh we're working on some
histograms that show with range sliders
so we can bring some more meaning to a
range slider let people kind of
investigate the data a little bit that
way
and this is all kind of showing changing
what's showing on the right
now let's move on to the cards here
um
cards are amazing sometimes people put a
lot of cards on a page
it can get to be a lot my kind of rule
of thumb is if you reach seven cards
maybe it's time to start looking at
making a new page
but in this case we've got this globe
here and it's kind of showing some data
and it's a little hard to kind of make
out what it's doing so we've added a
full screen feature to make a card Go
full screen
and so now
you can kind of play with this with a
bit more uh real estate you can kind of
zoom in if you want
let's see oh
well
that card to the right I zoomed in and
uh I was able to
um see a bit more information
about to get the light here so I want to
talk about I want to talk about value
boxes real quick we're going to make
value boxes you can put an icon up in
the corner it's just kind of an HTML
space I was sitting next to the dude who
made plotly so I said can we have a
spark line for an icon he said sure this
is great for the boss who is uh looking
at this but maybe you want to be able to
click in and see a bit more so value
boxes can be full screen and you can
kind of see more information I don't
know if you notice but now there's an X
and Y axis you can show more stuff
all right I'm about to get the gong here
so let me just say
um I think this will be especially
powerful when it comes to tables
all of this comes from conversations
with you we'd love to hear from you and
find out what you're struggling with and
how we can maybe help so reach out my
email is Greg rstudio.com and I'd love
to hang out
[Applause]
[Music]